سواء من الاردن ومصر سالنا الناس من هو
الممثل العربي الاكثر واسامه
[موسيقى]
العربي معتصم النهار صراحه
وتمثيل برضه تمثيل وحلو كثير يعني شكله
وسيم وحسن وجده شخصيته حلوه وائل شرف
بصراحه اييه امم
تمثيله بصراحه كثير مبدع بارع بحب تمثيله
انا
اعتقد الممثل المصري احمد عز يعني او سم
واحد من سوريا
انا شايف ان ممكن لو فنان مصري
كريم عبد العزيز ولو فنان مش مصري ممكن
اقول الفنان جمال سليمان انا بنقدر اشوف
ان اوسم فنان عربي عندي ناصر القصبي طبعا
انا شايف اوسم فنان عربي هو عبد حسين عبد
الرضا اوسم فنان عربي وائل جسار انا شايفه
اوسم فنان عربي ممكن بس الخياط مع انه
توكسيك بس وسيم اوسم فنان عربي من وجهه
نظري محمود ياسين في السينما عربي اقدر
اقول لك عليه كريم عبد العزيز كريم عبد
العزيز شاب ناجح ادواره حلوه
[موسيقى]